j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour il porte sur la
recrudescence des affaires d'espionnage
la guerre en ukraina réactivé les
services de renseignement plusieurs
experts internationaux affirment que
l'Europe est entré dans la décennie des
espions qui sont ces nouveaux agents
qu'elle roulent jouer le logiciel et
nouvelle technologie avant d'en débattre
Renaud parquet nous présente ses
nouveaux moyens et comment les États les
utilisent
la guerre en Ukraine les a révélées les
drones sont aujourd'hui indispensables
aux armes et aux États à la fois comme
bombardier comme moyen de renseignements
les services de renseignement ont envie
de compris l'intérêt que cette
technologie peuvent offrir pour capter
de l'information d'Internet en passant
par les cyberattaques ou l'intelligence
artificielle une multiplication des
sources donc qui permet d'avoir de plus
en plus d'informations mais peuvent
s'avérer problématiques selon cette
ancienne officier des services de
renseignement extérieur les listes de
base qui analysent aussi bien des
renseignements humains d'origine humaine
que des renseignements techniques là il
y a un progrès énorme mais ce progrès
est
contrebalancé par le fait que le pauvre
analyse a une telle masse d'informations
maintenant à étudier que certaines
malgré les prix techniques qui peuvent
être faits et bien il peut arriver à
laisser passer la pépite qui était
extrêmement vraiment importante parce
que la masse d'information tue
l'information alors il a fallu se
réformer une transformation que la
France a mis en place à compter de 2010
en décloisonnant les services et en
changeant de méthodologie avec le temps
l'analyse est devenue nécessaire et voir
indispensable aujourd'hui pourquoi parce
que
l'évolution des capteurs la
multiplication des sources de
renseignements la nécessaire expertise
ou multi expertise en fait pour pour
créer de la connaissance stratégique
nécessite aujourd'hui de récolter
l'information de multiples capteurs
multiples sources et de la transformer
en connaissance au profit du décideur
des décideurs au rang de chefs d'État
qui ont changé aussi de posture
vis-à-vis des services de renseignement
de défiance souffrance en Mitterrand ou
Jacques Chirac les services secrets ont
obtenu de plus en plus de crédit auprès
des derniers présidents Sarkozy Hollande
et Macron quelle est la réalité tout de
suite mes invités pour ce second débat
le général Christophe gomard bonsoir
bienvenue ancien chef du renseignement
militaire Antoine Isambard bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
journaliste au service international de
challenge côte
de ce livre trahison à la DGSE et puis
auteur de France Chine les liaisons
dangereuses qui les deux je crois sont
publiés aux éditions Stock on est bon
Anne Poiret bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste réalisatrice notamment de ce
documentaire projet Pegasus un espion de
votre poche qui est en ce moment
disponible sur la plateforme de nos
confrères d'Arte Mathieu croissanto est
resté évidemment à mes côtés les
nouveaux espions qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire qui sont ces nouveaux espions
vous me diriez ça il y a toujours des
espions
en tout cas il y a les agents de
renseignement le terme espion est
utilisé mais ce sont des agents de
renseignements quel que soit le service
d'ailleurs avec des services qui ont pas
exactement les mêmes rôles les mêmes
moyens ni les mêmes capacités
je suis pas sûr non ce qui change des
nouveaux moyens peut-être ce sont des
nouveaux moyens et surtout ce qui change
en France c'est la création d'une
coordination nationale du renseignements
en 2008 précédé par la création d'une
délégation pour la menteur enseignement
c'est-à-dire en fait l'arrivée un peu du
Parlement la vraie question d'ailleurs
c'était comment est-ce qu'on contrôle
ces services de renseignement et surtout
beaucoup de nouveaux moyens avec en
particulier tout ce qui touche à
l'Internet tout ce qui touche au monde
du cyber et aujourd'hui avec apparaît ce
qu'on appelle l'Open Source l'Open
Source donc en fait le renseignement
ouvert et la guerre en Ukraine nous
montre bien c'est d'un seul coup on a
une masse d'informations qui arrivent
sont-elles vraies fausses est-ce qu'on a
les moyens de recouper et une nation
comme la France à la chance bénéficier
de 6 services de renseignement qui
permettent d'avoir une appréciation
autonome des situations et donc au
président de la République de prendre
des décisions
exactement pas être trop ou pas être du
tout ne pas être du tout dépend des
autres alors bien sûr ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas d'échanges et de dire du
Benz parking ça qu'on s'appuie sur ce
Cora contre les autres pour vérifier
mais on a les capacités d'avoir une
vision autonome de situation
Antoine ils ont reçu on se penche là sur
les profils des agents de renseignement
des espions qui sont recrutés en ce
moment par la DGSE c'est plutôt des
geeks c'est plutôt des est-ce qu'il y a
un changement de profil une certaine
façon ouais 5 ans regarde notamment il y
a beaucoup de mathématiciens de
cryptographes de gens qui sont dans
l'intelligence artificielle et qui ont
vocation à intégrer la direction
technique de la DGSE qui fait à peu près
entre 2500 et 3000 agents sur les 7000
de la DGSE et qui est devenu assez vrai
le service on va dire
phare et qui est monté en puissance et
qui est capable de casser des codes
informatiques et capable de d'avoir tout
un tas d'informations par des moyens
technologiques et aujourd'hui c'est
véritablement on le voit notamment je
crois dans la saison 4 du bureau des
légendes ou c'est eux qui vont réussir à
à introduire des formateroles et on voit
une attaque à un moment donné donc voilà
après il y a encore un recrutement je
dirais plus à l'ancienne avec des
linguistes des analystes pays qui sont
recrutés et qui vont
finalement faire le travail un peu
traditionnel et historique d'un service
de renseignement mais c'est vrai que la
transformation la révolution
technologique aujourd'hui on le voit
avec des profils vraiment de geek qui
sont assez compliqués d'ailleurs à
fidéliser et à garder parce que c'est
des profils assez rares donc en termes
de salaire au bout de deux trois ans
souvent ben ils partent ils vont chez
Google ou chez d'autres et donc ça c'est
un peu la problématique aussi des
services français c'est de conserver ces
profils là assez rares on va évidemment
parler de Pegasus en détail ce sera
l'indice de zébat mais plus généralement
on est quoi on est face à des progrès du
numérique peut-être de l'intelligence
artificielle à qui ont vraiment est-ce
que vous diriez vous aussi que c'est une
nouvelle ère qui a démarré il y a
quelques années oui absolument c'est des
outils qui sont qui n'existaient
absolument pas qui sont
extraordinairement intrusifs Pegasus a
marché comme ça c'était incroyablement
bien vendu parce que c'était très de
nouveau à ce moment-là alors en quelques
mots c'est quoi alors c'est un logiciel
c'est un spyware qui permet de
la personne qu'il utilise de rentrer
entièrement dans votre téléphone
portable c'est à dire que peu importe
les outils que vous utilisez de cryptage
le logiciel est sur votre téléphone
c'est pour ça on dit comme il était
derrière votre épaule parce qu'en fait
vous ne pouvez pas vous en défendre il
est dedans en fait donc il voit ce que
vous voyez il entend ce que vous voyez
les textos que vous écrivez les messages
sur signal les messages sur n'importe
quel messagerie tout ce que vous faites
avec votre téléphone ce logiciel
ces attaques qui mettent en place que
qui s'organise qui passe et les les
c'est ce qu'on reproche d'ailleurs Apple
et au grand géant de l'informatique
c'est de pas protéger assez et si vous
voulez les utiliser des failles qui sont
en permanence
comblées par ces gaffes et qui en
permanence sont contournés par ces gens
qui sont des génies de l'informatique
chez ce groupe il recrute énormément des
gens qui sont des anciens des services
de renseignement israéliens qui sont
absolument les meilleurs pour parce que
c'est une entreprise israélienne qui a
sportive
absolument
allez-y bon alors on va continuer on va
élargir un peu parce que
on parle des des nouveaux outils
notamment informatique mais c'est pas
les seules sources d'un renseignement on
peut peut-être les lister si on fait un
peu de pédagogie alors si vous voulez
encore de l'humain quand même absolument
en fait vous avez quatre types de
renseignements vous allez renseignements
humains donc des sources humaines soit
qui sont j'allais dire manipuler soit
qui raconte d'elle-même soit des gens
qui voient enfin des soldats formés pour
ça des agents formés pour ça qu'ils vont
raconter ce qu'il voit vous avez les
interceptions électromagnétiques en fait
ce qu'on appelle vulgairement les
écoutes parce qu'il y a toujours un tas
d'informations qui passent via de parler
satellites par exemple de communication
et vous avez également l'imagerie à la
fois l'imagerie grâce aux satellites
d'observation militaire dit optique et
vous avez également tout ce qui touche
au monde du cybernétique en fait vous
avez quatre types de renseignements j'ai
rajouté le cinquième dont on a commencé
à parler c'est le renseignement de
source ouverte mais derrière ce sont des
hommes ou des femmes qui à la fois vont
recueillir du enseignement dit humain ou
qui vont j'allais dire observer reculer
l'information grâce au satellites
d'observation qui vont intercepté qui
ensuite vont analyser donc dans un
service de renseignement vous avez
besoin de gens qui s'occupent des
capteurs qui vont recueillir ce
renseignement vous avez besoin
d'analystes qui vont exploiter
l'information et besoin de gens qui vont
diffuser cette information donc en fait
c'est ça c'est vous bénéficiez de tous
les moyens qui permettent de donner un
point de vue qui explique une situation
et l'idée d'un service de l'enseignement
c'est de chercher à anticiper pour
prévenir d'une attaque pour prévenir
j'allais dire d'une menace en tenue
embar il y a un exemple récent soit de
cyberattaque coordonnées par les
services chinois donc il y a c'est quoi
un malware c'est ça
qui est utilisé alors j'aurais qu'on
fasse la part de la technologie et de
l'humain justement pour rester un peu
dans cette thématique pas c'est pas
assez c'est forcément l'un avec l'autre
quoi d'une certaine façon ça a été un
peu l'alliance des deux et ça aboutit en
fin d'année dernière sur la compte de la
première condamnation d'un responsable
du ministère de la Sécurité d'État qui
est le plus gros service de
renseignement chinois aux États-Unis
et donc c'est dans les années 2013 14 il
y a eu donc une vaste opération de
d'espionnage et de cyberespionnage à
lancé par la Chine contre des groupes
aéronautiques dont ça fera en France
général électrique aux États-Unis
alors il y a un peu tout il y a eu un
peu toute la palette côté safran ils ont
réussi à s'introduire à introduire un
malware en fait dans un ordinateur d'un
cadre de safran un malware c'est un
virus d'infecter l'ordinateur de du
cadre de safran et de remonter d'avoir
après éventuellement des documents
techniques qui ont permis à la Chine
après de concevoir son propre avion et
côté américain ça a été un petit peu du
hame on va dire donc ils ont réussi à
contacter des gens via LinkedIn et après
c'est noué une relation donc ils les ont
invités en Chine des salariés de gérer
Electric donc invité dans des hôtels de
luxe invités à faire des conférences ils
étaient payés et donc là il y avait un
officier très étanche chinois donc
yanouit une relation et ça aboutit à un
moment donné à ce que l'officier très
étend chinoise se déplace en Europe à
Bruxelles et là il a été arrêté par les
autorités bruxelloises et il était
extradi 6 mois plus tard aux États-Unis
et donc il a été condamné en 2022 mais
voilà on a souvent c'est un levier c'est
un moyen le technique mais derrière il y
a un officier traitant il y a quelqu'un
qui doit être capable d'extraire leur
enseignement parce que si vous récoltez
du renseignement mais que vous n'êtes
pas capable de l'analyser ça sert à rien
donc allez on va rentrer dans le détail
de cette affaire Pegasus je vous propose
une première réaction celle de katiaou
qui est chargé de plaidoyer liberté à
Amnesty International France et elle
rappelle un peu qui a été visé
mondiale qui a été menée par le
consortium le journaliste forbidjan
stories en lien avec Amnesty
International a révélé que des
gouvernements clients de l'entreprise
NSE une entreprise de cyber surveillance
israélienne utilisée le logiciel espion
Pegasus pour cibler pour espionner des
personnes qui sont des défenseurs des
droits humains des journalistes ou des
personnalités politiques
issues de la société civile on peut
retrouver le nom dédoué pleinel ou de
Dominique Simoneau donc des journalistes
très connus français hier on a pu
révéler par exemple qu'Emmanuel Macron
faisait partie de la liste des personnes
d'intérêts ça ne veut pas dire qu'il a
été ciblée par le logiciel mais bien
qu'il fait partie de cette liste avec le
Premier ministre de l'époque donc
Édouard Philippe puisque c'était en 2019
et puis un certain nombre de ministres
de son gouvernement le roi du Maroc
aussi Mohammed VI fait partie de cette
liste
quels sont les états qui ont utilisé
Pegasus
alors les États qui sont en fait il y a
deux choses à faire le projet Pegasus
c'est une liste de 50 000 numéros qui
ont été à un moment donné qui ont
éveillé l'intérêt d'un certain nombre de
gouvernements ça veut pas dire que ce
sont tous les clients de
NS au groupe il y en a beaucoup d'autres
donc c'est la société israélienne qui a
créé
ce que révèle la liste c'est notamment
des pays qui sont des pays
problématiques c'est à dire que NSO
groupe dit nous nous vendons à des états
qui sont responsables et qui ont besoin
de ces outils pour lutter contre la
pédocrinalité contre le
les criminels notamment le premier
client de Pegasus en 2011 a été le
Mexique et qui évidemment vivait à ce
moment-là la guerre des cartels il y
avait besoin de de faire quelque chose
vous avez tout à fait légitime à dire
nous avons besoin de cet outil pour nous
défendre et écouter ces cartels qu'ils
ont infiltrées les services de l'État
sauf que le Mexique l'État endroit le
contrôle dans l'état mexicain on fait
que dans cette liste il y avait 15000
numéros qui étaient des numéros
mexicains et énormément d'entre eux
étaient des opposants des journalistes
des étudiants des gens qui avaient
essayé d'avoir gain de cause dans des
disparitions voilà donc c'est donc il y
a le premier État qui est le Mexique et
puis après devant ce succès important
pour NSE au groupe ils se sont mis à
vendre à beaucoup d'autres gouvernements
et on retrouve dans le fichier le Maroc
l'Azerbaïdjan les Émirats arabes unis
l'Arabie Saoudite et des États européens
dont la Hongrie et après il y a eu des
révélations après le scandale de Pegasus
qui est en juillet 2021 un choc mondial
de de une prise de conscience de ce que
ce que à quoi peut conduire ce commerce
de ce type d'outils d'autres révélations
sont sorties notamment en Europe on
s'est rendu compte que la Pologne avait
espionné des opposants que l'Espagne
aussi il y avait un syndrome de gens qui
avaient été infecté notamment le Premier
ministre de l'époque voilà donc c'est
des députés européens se sont retrouvés
sur cette liste pardon pas sur cette
liste infectée donc voilà il y a eu une
espèce de prise de conscience qu'en fait
c'était très proche de nous
j'ai une question en fait chaque pays
achetait Pegasus il faisait ce qu'il
voulait avec ou il devait repasser par
la société israélienne pour l'utiliser
pour toucher les numéros dont vous
parliez voilà alors c'est toute
l'ambiguïté de NSO qui dit nous on livre
cet outil au gouvernement et on a
absolument pas de contrôle dessus et
évidemment il y a pas de backdoor du
gouvernement israélien vous êtes
absolument Gabriel alors quand on leur
demande mais vous avez un contrôle vous
devez pouvoir quand comment vous faites
en fait pour contrôler puisque vous vous
contentez de la parole de ces
gouvernements dont on peut douter alors
là il s'entortille un peu et la la
l'audition devant la commission
d'enquête l'année dernière qui est dans
le film d'un
au patron de NSO groupe qui est venu
s'expliquer tenter de s'expliquer était
très
révélatrice de cette espèce de d'entre
eux en disant non on ne contrôle pas
mais en même temps on peut vous dire que
personne n'a été espionné que même
manuel Macron n'est absolument pas été
visé par notre outil donc en fait ils
sont pris un peu entre cette obligation
par rapport aux clients de dire non non
on a aucun contrôle sur votre vous êtes
absolument évidemment que nous ne spions
donc pas on n'a pas les infos que vous
extrayez des des gens que vous espionnez
et en même temps de pouvoir dire non non
on contrôle et ce n'est pas sur le alors
un moment donné il s'est quand même
retrouvé à dire que en fait c'est devant
les parlementaires qu'en fait souvent
c'est déclencher des contrôles quand il
y avait des enquêtes journalistiques
donc là évidemment des révélations
journalistiques tout en disant le projet
Pegasus est un ramassis de
mensuels puissent déclencher ça et ça
pose un tout petit problème démocratique
effectivement on va on va alors vous
l'avez dit il y a eu la question autour
de Emmanuel Macron espionner ou pas
Mathieu il y a des précédents quand même
concernant le chef de l'État
Macron est encore espionné aujourd'hui
ça peut-être on ne sait pas ce qu'on va
dire l'espionnage est-ce qu'on sait
est-ce qu'on sait pas est-ce qu'on saura
jamais donc on verra mais en tout cas
pour lui ça a commencé souvenez-vous
avant même qu'il n'arrive à l'Elysée
d'une certaine façon puisque à 48 heures
du premier tour du second tour pardon de
de la présidentielle et ben il y a eu
des pirates qui étaient d'origine encore
inconnues même si on a beaucoup de
soupçons aujourd'hui qui avait divulgué
plus de 20000 mails il y a sa campagne 9
giga octet de données reliés par des
robots et des spammers une échelle
industrielle sur internet alors les
fuites n'ont pas empêché Emmanuel Macron
de se faire élire vous savez c'est les
fameuses Macron lips mais plusieurs
enquêtes de presse ils verront une
tentative d'ingérence étrangère et
reliront cette suite à des hackers
vraiment pour des services de
renseignement oui c'est même peut-être
le service de renseignement militaire
russe et puis une fois élu le président
il sera aussi la cible de pays alliés
Pegasus justement puisqu'elle était 2021
Emmanuel Macron découvre dans une
enquête de presse donc son numéro de
téléphone figure sûr vous l'avez bien
expliqué une liste de cibles
potentielles du logiciel Pegasus
fabriqué donc par une société
israélienne l'utilisateur de ce logiciel
espion en l'occurrence ce sont les
services enseignement marocains qui
voilà qui ont fait cette liste de cible
potentiels Macron n'est pas le seul en
faire partie vous l'avez dit Édouard
Philippe Jean-Yves Le Drian qui était
l'époque mise à faire étrangers qui
savent Castaner le milieu intérieur
jardin ou nommé mais aussi des
journalistes alors rien ne dit que le
téléphone d'Emmanuel Macron a été
infecté et donc écouté ou espionner mais
devant l'emploi du risque quand même on
se souvient que le Président de la
République réunit un Conseil de sécurité
intérieure et changera d'appareil comme
de numéro de téléphone et comment
l'Élysée réagit et éventuellement
riposte mais j'ai envie de dire comme
toujours dans ces moments là en poussant
des cris d'orfray quand on prend les
communiquer les interventions des
ministres c'est inacceptable toute la
lumière doit être faite voilà bref mais
les relations entre Paris et Rabat
seront particulièrement tendus Emmanuel
Macron s'expliquera aussi avec le
Premier ministre israélien qui a un
aphtali Bennett de l'époque parce que le
gouvernement israélien devait donner son
tampon pour que Pegasus sorte puisque
c'était quand même comme un matériel
militaire quoi un matériel sensible mais
souvent en fait c'est fâcheries entre
alliés ne sont que de courte durée tiens
je vous ai un autre exemple fin mai 2021
la télévision publique danoise révèle
que plusieurs personnalités politiques
européennes de premier plan ont été
espionnés par la NSA cette fois-ci donc
l'agence de sécurité américaine qui
avait détourné avec peut-être ou non
l'accord des droits c'est jamais été
vraiment très clair les câbles
sous-marins notamment
installés par le Danemark et par les
1000 les victimes de ces grandes
oreilles Angela Merkel mais aussi des
personnalités françaises alors là en
tant que chef de l'État ça se passait
pas sous le mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
mais dans le monde la précédent mais
comme c'est Emmanuel Macron qui est à
l'Élysée à ce moment-là il dit que c'est
inacceptable encore une fois entre
allier il évoque des enquêtes des
protestations diplomatiques mais voilà
on a toujours rien vu vraiment venir sur
ce qui était qui veut vraiment été
entendu pourquoi qu'ils ont été une
enquête les résultats mais je crois que
ces conflits ne se règle jamais au grand
jour mais plutôt en coulisse encore plus
qu'obser entre allier évidemment
Christophe gomard enfin on espionne
ateliers mais aussi alors
un service de renseignement c'est fait
pour connaître les intentions d'un
adversaire au départ de savoir quelles
sont ces plans et bien évidemment un
salon de pays potentiellement adverse
effectivement c'est fait pour tenter de
connaître les attentions donc oui
qu'Emmanuel Macron que nos présidents de
la République ait été espionné par des
services étrangers c'est sûr même oui
quand c'est des alliés c'est c'est autre
chose c'est plus compliqué et
souvenons-nous il y a une crise avec les
services américains je crois même qu'il
y a eu des diplomates américains qui ont
été renvoyés parce qu'effectivement les
Américains
ont absolument intercepté
ou chercher intercepter l’élysées en
particulier quand vous voyez le
l'emplacement de l'ambassade américaine
à Paris rue du Faubourg Saint-Honoré je
ne sais plus quel numéro mais c'est pas
loin du 55 rue du Faubourg Saint-Honoré
où se situe l'Élysée donc effectivement
il y avait des antennes bizarroïdes sur
le toit de l'ambassade américaine qui
était recouverte par l'espèce de bâche
ou de fausses d'une maison
complètement construite donc oui ça
existe on est même allé jusqu'à prévoir
un accord de non-espionnage réciproque
ce qui ne s'est jamais fait donc c'est
la preuve que non nous ne renseignons
pas sur nos alliés mais on s'intéresse
quand même à ce qu'ils font à ce qu'il
pense à tel point c'est que on a accusé
les services français de ne pas avoir vu
venir aucus donc vous savez
oculus c'est l'affaire des sous-marins
de la vente de sous-marin à l'Australie
et cette alliance entre l'Australie la
Grande-Bretagne et les États-Unis
changement d'alliance absolument est-ce
qu'on peut tout savoir en terme de
renseignement et d'intelligence
économique ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence économique c'est
compliqué parce que bien sûr tout ce qui
produit l'armement tout ce qui on
s'intéresse à savoir ce que les
capacités adverses ou ce qu'ils vont
vendre à un pays qui pourraient les
utiliser contre la France ou les
intérêts français donc oui c'est le
renseignement c'est très large très
vaste c'est pour ça qu'il faut des
hommes et des femmes bien formés pour
pouvoir analyser d'abord recueillir la
vraie la vraie difficulté c'est toutes
ces données dont on a parlé c'est ce
qu'on appelle les datas on parle de Big
Data effectivement c'est cette capacité
dans un monde très numérisé encore plus
numérisé après le covid qu'avant le
covid parce qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
est équipé de d'ordinateurs portables de
téléphone et donc tout passe par là donc
l'idée c'est d'intercepter à travers les
câbles à travers les communications ce
qui se dit ou ce qui se raconte
effectivement ce qui intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui se passe en
Ukraine ce que pense à Vladimir Poutine
ce que raconte un prix gaugine ce que
raconte même à zeinski pour savoir
exactement quels sont ses intentions
même si c'est un allié du coup juste une
petite question est-ce qu'on est plus
vulnérable aujourd'hui qu'il y a 50 ans
on peut peut-être poser la question
on est à la fois plus vulnérable mais en
même temps ça nous permet d'être plus
offensif aussi donc ça c'est un peu
compliqué de aujourd'hui en matière
économique c'est vrai que c'est devenu
enfin l'espionnage économique
l'ingérence économique est devenu une
priorité et voilà à part justement à la
révolution technologique qui a
énormément de choses qui sont faites
alors on parlait il hiérarchie dans les
services de renseignement comme il y en
a en fait dans les pays donc rivalisez
nous aujourd'hui des GSE
DRM ou des GSI avec le FBI la NSA ou la
CIA c'est compliqué quand on voit en
terme de moyens tout simplement la
Communauté française du renseignement
c'est à peu près 20.000
hommes et femmes et aux Etats-Unis c'est
100 000 à peu près c'est 80 milliards de
budget là-bas donc voilà mais il
n'empêche qu'il y a des particularités
et nous en France on a plutôt je dirais
une la direction technique de la DGSE ou
la DRM sont plutôt bons sur le technique
mais je rappelle direction du
renseignant militaire voilà mais il y a
aussi une réputation française d'être
assez bon dans l'enseignement humain de
savoir traiter des sources et de savoir
faire finalement du renseignement avec
moins de moyens que la concurrence les
Britanniques et voilà et donc la France
joue un peu là dessus et nous dans
challenge avant dernier on avait
interrogé deux anciens directeurs de la
CIA sur comment ils voyaient la DGSE et
pour eux il l'a classé parmi leurs trois
dans le top 3 de leur partenaire
mondiaux donc voilà c'était quand même
pas mal avec des moyens qui augmentent
je vous donne la parole tout de suite je
vous donne juste un chiffre c'est il
vient de la loi de programmation
militaire en y consacré un débat lundi
en ce début de semaine plus 60% de
crédit prévu en plus pour les services
de renseignement français donc sur la
durée de la LPM donc 2024
vous lui intervenir est-ce que on se
pose suffisamment la question de l'usage
qu'on fait de ces de ces nouveaux moyens
ces logiciels etc dans nos démocraties
mais c'est ça que je voulais là où je
voulais intervenir parce que là on a un
débat sur des cibles légitimes un ennemi
d'un état voilà dans un contexte de
conflit mais la question que pose cette
liste est Pegasus c'est l'énormité des
des cibles et la facilité absolument
hallucinante que donne ses outils pour
espionner vous demander comment on
rentre en fait au début on recevait un
sms donc vous pouvez éventuellement se
dire je clique dessus mais très vite on
ne se rend absolument pas compte qu'on
est infecté et nous on a pu discuter
avec quelqu'un qui a eu qui a été un
utilisateur au Mexique de de Pegasus et
qui dit vraiment ça ne tient qu'à une
éthique personnelle de ne pas tout
aspirer de ne pas rentrer ses
vertigineux la on peut espionner tout le
monde avec un logiciel comme celui-là
un nombre de cible c'est à dire qu'ils
peuvent pour certains contrats certaines
licences ils ont 500
1500 donc c'est pour ça que ça neso au
groupe a pu dire une espèce de
comptabiliser cette liste c'est
impossible parce qu'on ne fait jamais
autant en fait c'est en temps réel donc
en fait c'est exponentiel simplement
c'est la quantité et la matière qui est
aspirée l'intimité dans lequel vous
rentrez
les gens qui utilisent ce logiciel enfin
cet outil nous dit c'est vertigineux
par un État démocratique c'est une vraie
question alors le Mexique on peut se
poser se poser la question mais on voit
bien que la Hongrie la Pologne où est-ce
qu'on se situe aujourd'hui on a ce
cette ce projet de loi qui est en train
de je pense qu'on va en parler où il
faut on se rend compte que quand même il
faut il faut qu'il y ait des amendes bon
pour qu'on dise attention il y a un
certain nombre de personnes la
géolocalisation géolocalisation sur
l'ouverture des caméras alors c'est
encadré on est dans une dans un état de
droit solide simplement c'est tellement
facile on sait tellement puissant que en
fait le risque et encore une fois ça
pose des questions démocratie c'est
derrière à quel moment un homme
politique une femme politique des
journalistes vont pouvoir fonctionner
avec le secret des sources protéger le
secret des sources protéger sur mon
recruteur on voit que toutes les cibles
dans le projet Pegasus beaucoup de CIPS
sont justement des journalistes qui
encaissent sur des très d'État sur des
choses complexes et ça c'est vraiment
une question un élément passionnant du
débat Christophe Goma est-ce qu'on peut
bien se protéger tout en voilà
respectant les principes d'une
démocratie moderne ou est-ce qu'il faut
forcément accepter collectivement qu'on
va renier sur certaines de nos libertés
pour pouvoir se protéger des dangers
liés à ces nouvelles technologies je
crois qu'en France on a le souci très
net
pas démocratique on a soucis très net
effectivement on n'est pas là pour faire
de l'espionnage de masse au sens où
c'est pas on n'est pas là pour espionner
le concitoyen en réalité évidemment on a
les outils pour le faire évidemment mais
en fait vous savez qu'il y a des
techniques de renseignement dit des
techniques qui sont de l'interception
qui sont de la pose de de micro etc ça
c'est encadré par la loi c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait vous avez une commission
nationale
des interceptions de sécurité qui
valident les demandes en fait chaque
service a le droit à un certain nombre
de demandes elle fait ses demandes c'est
demande ça va dans le Midi Chem de
tutelle qui valide ou pas d'ailleurs
ensuite ça va au cabinet Premier
ministre et ensuite ça va cette
commission
qui vérifie justement les demandes donc
en fait vous voyez le procédé donc c'est
assez long même si les lois
anti-terroriste ont quand même allégées
plus vite et ensuite c'est un contrôle
imposteur mais c'est une vraie question
c'est bien sûr la menace terroriste
est-ce qu'elle finit pas par nous amener
collectivement bien sûr à renoncer un
certain nombre de c'est vrai que en
France il existe un contrôle alors ce
contrôle il pourrait être peut-être plus
encore plus précis mais derrière on gêne
l'activité d'un centre de services j'ai
dit on a la chance de vivre dans un état
démocratique en France bon certains le
contestent mais en tous les cas pour
avoir été dans cet environnement pendant
plus de 10 ans à la fois au cabinet du
ministre de des armées à l'Élysée comme
patron des forces spéciales et comme
directeur durant militaire j'ai bien vu
comment ça se passait en fait c'est très
contrôlé d'ailleurs ce que crée en 2007
la délégation parlementaire en ce moment
on voit bien déjà qu'il y a une volonté
j'allais dire politique de voir ce que
des services et cette délégation
parlementaire petit à petit elle a
encore de plus en plus de pouvoir
vis-à-vis des services de contrôle des
services vous dites il y a suffisamment
de contrôle votre avis là-dessus non on
va aujourd'hui que la plupart des
services de renseignements y compris en
France leur grand rêve c'est d'arriver à
avoir les clés pour rentrer dans les
applications chiffrées comme WhatsApp
télégram ou signal et là ça pose
vraiment des questions parce que c'est
une question de liberté les gens sont
allés sur les applications aussi parce
qu'ils se sentaient libre et qui savait
qu'il serait pas écouté donc on a vu le
FBI il y avait demandé à effet des pieds
des mains pour demander à alors c'était
pas une la plus sécurisée mais Apple de
pouvoir rentrer dans dans le code en
fait du téléphone et Apple à un verre
fusée et je dirais sur la commission
qu'évoquait Christophe Gomart c'est
assez étonnant parce qu'il y a quelques
jours elle a rendu son rapport
annuel et justement elle s'alarmait un
petit peu du nombre de demandes faites
par les services de renseignement
français
sur des sujets politiques ou syndicaux
et elle jugeait que voilà c'était
probablement excessif et elle appelait à
ce que il est peut-être un petit peu de
régulation qui soit mis là-dedans voilà
et je dirais que la délégation
parlementaire renseignement qui était
créé qui est plutôt une bonne chose elle
a quand même pas des pouvoirs très
approfondis et je pense que là-dessus on
pourrait peut-être aller un peu plus
loin et quand on regarde les rapports de
la de la DPR ils sont certes honnête
mais il y a quand même beaucoup
d'informations qui sont
blanchies qu'on a dont on n'a pas accès
donc dans le rapport c'est normal
j'allais dire ce que l'on dit ils
peuvent pas mettre dans le rapport ce
que raconte les services ça on peut le
comprendre effectivement alors on sait
évidemment pas qui sont les espions
français d'aujourd'hui par définition ou
alors ils ont mal fait leur travail mais
alors avec Samia Dechy on va pouvoir
regarder un petit peu dans dans le
rétroviseur rebons soit Samia vous
revenez sur quelques grands noms de
l'espionnage français oui j'ai choisi
deux fans et deux hommes qui ont marqué
l'histoire on commence avec la deuxième
guerre mondiale une époque un qui
forcément a fait naître pas mal de
vocations d'espion pour lutter contre
les nazis à l'époque tout simplement par
goût du risque comme Mathilde carré qui
s'ennuie dans une vie trop bien rangée
en Algérie française en 1940 elle rentre
en France en tant qu'infirmière avant
finalement de choisir de devenir
espionne et une espionne très douée
visiblement assez connue surnommée la
chatte elle contribue à fonder le réseau
interalié qui va fournir beaucoup de
renseignements aux Anglais mais un an
plus tard elle retourne sa veste et elle
se met au service des renseignements
allemands à qui elle va livrer des
dizaines de noms de résistants ce qui
lui vaudra d'être condamné à mort après
la guerre mais l'ancien agent double
finalement sera gracié et libéré sans
qu'on sache vraiment pourquoi toi
évidemment oui les grands espions
d'époque ils sont plutôt russe ou
américains mais les Français ne sont pas
en reste
jean-clémentin par exemple que personne
ne soupçonnait c'était un journaliste
renommé rédacteur en chef quand même du
Canard Enchaîné le journaliste et espion
donc alias pipasse son nom de code
auprès des services secrets
tchécoslovaque qui la renseigné de 1957
1969 jean-clémentin a donc servi le camp
soviétique pendant 12 ans sans que la
France ne s'en rende compte et l'on n'en
savait rien jusqu'à l'an dernier ce
n'est qu'en 2022 que son rôle d'espion a
été révélé par un autre journaliste
Vincent Jover dans l'Obs jean-clémentin
et décédé en janvier dernier Dominique
prieur maintenant Dominique prieur ça
nous rappelle un grand scandale de
l'État
identité révélée au grand jour oui elle
aussi c'est la première à avoir intégré
la première femme à avoir intégré le
service action de la DGSE qu'elle
rejoint en 1977 elle a alors 28 ans elle
est envoyée en Nouvelle-Zélande sous une
fausse identité elle devient alors
sophiturange et forme avec un autre
agent le couple des faux-époux tu ranges
et c'est sous ce nom qu'elle est connue
pour avoir participé à l'attentat dont
vous parliez l'attentat contre le
Rainbow Warriors c'est en 1985 les
services secrets français font alors
sauter le navire de l'ONG Greenpeace qui
est qui est là pour protester contre les
essais nucléaires français Dominique
prieur alias sophiturange quel rôle elle
va jouer dans cette affaire et bien elle
va livrer les explosifs qui vont servir
à cette attaque perpétrée par la France
sur les dans les eaux néo-zélandaises
donc elle va être arrêtée par les
autorités néo-zélandaises et c'est là
donc son identité va être révélé au
monde entier c'est ce qu'il y a de pire
pour un espion elle est condamnée donc
forcément par la justice néo-zélandaise
et finalement elle sera rapatrié en
France trois ans plus tard et
aujourd'hui elle coule une retraite
paisible avec l'histoire presque la plus
savoureuse l'histoire d'un espion
amoureux oui il y a 20 ans Bernard
Boursicot jeune diplomate est envoyé à
Pékin où il tombe amoureux de ship et
qu'il croit être une chanteuse d'opéra
quelques années plus tard il lui annonce
qu'elle est enceinte la République
populaire de Chine va alors se servir de
cette relation pour le contraindre à
devenir son espion pour elle il va
choisir de trahir son pays pendant
plusieurs années mais en 1983 il est
démasqué et arrêté à Paris avec SHiPA
époux et c'est là qu'il va comprendre
que shippa époux n'est pas une femme
mais un homme un homme lui-même au
service des renseignements chinois
chargés de recruter les taupes comme lui
et que leur enfant est en fait un
orphelin chinois merci beaucoup Samia de
cheers dix ans de vie commune on peut
dire que l'amour rend aveugle bref on va
pas rentrer dans la timidité de leur
chambre à coucher il y a la Chine je
fais la transition avec vous parce que
vous avez enquêté sur l'espionnage
chinois c'est quoi c'est un vieil
espionnage c'est un espionnage au
contraire hyper technologique comme on
peut l'imaginer parce que la Chine est
plutôt en avance sur ces questions les
deux à la fois docteur oui c'est les
deux enfin on voit qu'aujourd'hui la
Chine est capable de des opérations à la
fois assez sophistiquées sur le plan
technique
si on regarde uniquement le cyber le la
grande offensive chinoise dans le cyber
est arrivé au début des années 2000 au
début c'était assez sommaire c'était
dans un immeuble en Chine on avait des
centaines de cit de l'Armée populaire de
libération qui ciblée ils ouvraient
l'annuaire c'était la lettre A ils
allaient cibler toutes les entreprises
de tel pays qui commençaient par la
lettre A le lendemain B enfin voilà
c'était assez avec des cyberattaques qui
avaient lieu toujours en heure de de
travail chinoise avec un code qui était
en mandarin donc facilement détectable
aujourd'hui c'est plus du tout le cas et
on a des opérations on a des créations
de malware chinois qui sont très de bon
niveau donc voilà après sur l'humain les
Chinois ont toujours su et je dirais
notamment avec les Français que les les
fameux leviers du dur enseignement les
fameux miles c'est-à-dire les leviers
pour retourner une source c'est l'ego
c'est l'argent c'est l'idéologie ou la
compromission
avec les Français par exemple sur les
questions de
d'égo ou de sexe c'était plutôt des bons
clients donc on a eu par le passé dans
l'histoire on va dire de la relation
entre les deux pays quelques cadres
retournement sur ces leviers là c'est
assez impressionnante comme pour Sico
par exemple même si pour psycho à pas
transmis énormément de documents mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a toujours un peu ce
côté
romantique mais les Chinois savent très
bien jouer tout ça et aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué de dire est-ce que ils sont
plus dans l'enseignement humain ou
technique ils font comme tout le monde
ils sont parmi les meilleurs services de
renseignement du monde et ils savent
très bien manier les deux enfin quand
même le chanteur la chanteuse d'opéra
qui était un homme ça ça moi je ça
restera l'histoire de la soirée pardon
allez on ouvre un dernier chapitre dans
ce dans ce débat consacré à la à la
guerre en
Ukraine parce que depuis février 2022 on
a vu se multiplier les expulsions de de
diplomates depuis beaucoup de pays
d'Europe on va prendre un exemple
polonais alors on est juste après le
déclenchement de la guerre parce qu'on
est en mars 2022 et le porte-parole du
ministère polonais des Affaires
étrangères dit ceci
du personnel ont reçu l'ordre de quitter
le territoire polonais d'ici 5 jours la
Russie mène une guerre barbare contre
l'Ukraine depuis plus de trois semaines
et nous les autres pays occidentaux nous
sommes traités par la Russie comme son
adversaire clé toléré ultérieurement ce
genre d'activité illégale des services
russes menacerait particulièrement la
sécurité de la Pologne et celle de nos
alliés de l'OTAN et de l'Union
européenne avec qui nous coordonnons
toutes nos activités de ce genre alors
ça a continué la la plus récemment
mi-avril la Norvège a encore envoyé 15
diplomates russes vers Moscou ça
représente quand même un tiers du
personnel diplomatique la France et
sauvegomard a expulsé une quarantaine de
diplomates russes depuis le début de la
guerre est-ce que ça veut dire que ils
sont devenus plus actifs avec la guerre
ou que au contraire les pays décident de
médiatiser ses expulsions alors que il
le faisait pas forcément auparavant ces
expulsions sont toujours médiatisées en
fait vous avez deux types d'agents
d'enseignement vous avez des agents qui
sont des agents déclarés dont on connaît
l'existence si on faisait des agents
sous couverture qui ne sont pas déclarés
cela c'est difficile de savoir si qu'ils
sont et s'il reste donc en fait vous
sortez vous et les expulser vous
expulsez des diplomates entre guillemets
le fameux attachés culturels de
l'Ambassade etc et ses adjoints c'est
cela que vous expulsez donc en fait ce
sont oui c'est c'est la part émerger de
l'iceberg enseignement du pays en
question c'est à dire en fait il est là
pour prendre contact avec les autres et
les autres ambassades des autres
services de renseignement voir avec les
services de renseignement locaux enfin
des pays pour discuter avec eux
ça les anciens on discute toujours même
lorsqu'il y a guerre il y a toujours des
discussions on entend pas parler
évidemment mais quand vous avez des
échanges prisonniers ça se fait par ce
biais là quand vous avez des débuts
négociations ça passe par ce biais là
donc oui il y a toujours une publicité
qui avait autour de ça comme quand on
avait expulsé des des diplomates
américains c'est l'occasion de montrer
une certaine fermeté vis-à-vis du pays
c'est vrai que l'ambassade de Russie à
Paris est bien connu parce que on dirait
un gros blockhaus et donc dans lequel il
y a pas mal de jaillir de de diplomates
c'est une grosse ambassade même chose
pour les Américains à Paris c'est une
grosse ambassade et la France c'est la
même chose la France a le deuxième
réseau diplomatique au monde quand même
donc en fait on a un réseau très
important mais est-ce que cette guerre
en Ukraine ça ouvre une nouvelle ère ou
une aire différente dans dans
l'espionnage
non ce qui est nouveau dans cette guerre
c'est c'est bien sûr les données et
c'est surtout je trouve c'est le fait
que les Américains par exemple annoncent
ouvertement
l'invasion c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
dans les jours assez précis sur ce
premier élément donc une espèce de
transparence et le deuxième élément
c'est le renseignement ouvert c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui il y a des tas de ce
que j'appelle les hausser donc Open
Source intelligence qui vont se
s'échanger des images vidéos et on les
voit d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on voit sur
nos chaînes de télévision et des
différents médias sur les réseaux
sociaux on voit des tas d'image qui sont
prises par des personnes des soldats sur
le front qui les font qui les relais
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'open source et
donc vous avez des réseaux de gens qui
font du rassemblement ouvert et qui
s'échangent d'informations entre eux et
grâce à ça vous avez une vision assez
précise de la situation militaire sur le
front par exemple c'est assez nouveau le
gros avantage à service c'est que vous
allez recouper ces informations pour
éviter d'être vous-même intoxiqué aux
manipuler parce que le but d'un service
c'est également de vous intoxiquez et de
vous manipuler pour vous amener à penser
quelque chose les les Russes sont assez
fort là dedans c'est ce qui s'appelle la
masse qui revient qu'en fait ils se sont
les rois la désinformation mais les
Ukrainiens sont quand même parce qu'en
fait ils ont été formés dans les mêmes
écoles donc oui ce qu'il raconte c'est
la propagande c'est la formation il y a
une part de vrai souvent pour
crédibiliser mais ce qui est autour
n'est pas forcément vrai est-ce
que à votre connaissance le l'Etat russe
à utiliser Pegasus ou alors de toute
façon possède des technologies
similaires alors j'ai pas ce genre de
d'informations Israël a été dans une
position assez compliquée parce que en
effet l'Ukraine leur a demandé des ce
genre d'outils
théoriquement dans un pays en guerre
c'est quand même un peu compliqué de
donc voilà il s'est retrouvé un peu dans
cette position un peu compliqué ce qui
est intéressant avec Pegasus c'est comme
il y a les autorisations d'Israël on lit
la politique étrangère israélienne et
donc on lit les accords d'Abraham c'est
pour ça que le Maroc a eu Pegasus c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on les des 80
journalistes qui ont travaillé sur ce
projet ont pu montrer que le
rapprochement avec les Émirats arabes
unis aussi c'était voilà il y avait ils
sont défend absolument en disant rien
mais ensuite quand même une forme de
donc par exemple Azerbaïdjan c'est la
frontière de l'Iran l'Iran et l'ennemi
juré d'Israël tout ça s'articule sur une
politique étrangère et donc
effectivement la Russie et le ça a été
quelque chose
d'extrêmement compliqué à gérer pour les
Israéliens de de se positionner sans
avoir l'air de de se positionner sur les
sanctions par exemple sur les sur les
Russes en disant c'est de l'espionnage à
l'ancienne les Russes ou pas ils savent
tout faire parce qu'ils sont assez bons
en technique et il y a de très bon
mathématiciens là-bas donc ils savent
faire après c'est vrai que sur le ce qui
remonte un peu à la une des médias
depuis notamment
2018 avec les attentats enfin les
opérations du GRU qui a essayé
d'assassiner ce scripal qui s'en est
pris à des trafics en bulgare qui a qui
avait une base logistique en
Haute-Savoie pour un peu tuer en Europe
tout ce qui était contre les intérêts de
Poutine voilà c'est plutôt gros sabot un
peu piednickelé
mais il s'affaire et juste un mot
là-dessus et ça recoupe sur l'usine
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a un site par
exemple comme bellinkat qui fait de
l'usine et qui a réussi justement à
montrer qui était les ce qui a voulu
tuer ce scripta en Angleterre donc des
gens du GRU et naval ni pareil a réussi
avec des sources probablement ouvertes
mais pas que à montrer les gens du FSB
qui avaient essayé de l'empoisonner et
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a
quand même toute une une petite mosaïque
de gens qui arrivent à faire des
découvertes et à montrer des choses qui
avant était plus compliquées à montrer
un peu plus dans la lumière merci
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vais peut-être les titres de vos livres
Antoine zambard trahison à la DGSE le
voici et puis Francine lelise les
liaisons dangereuses aux éditions Stock
et à me préparer votre documentaire sur
Pegasus c'est avoir sur la plateforme
d'Arte voilà de ma merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité vous pouvez
retrouver nos programmes sur la
plateforme public c'est la point FR et
puis notez que l'invité de la matinale
demain l'invité politique c'est
Christian Cambron le président de la
commission les affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées ici au
Sénat belle soirée